là tout n'est qu'ordre et beauté luxe
calme et volupté
ces mots de baudelaire illustre la
sensation que l'on a dans cette cour des
senteurs à 100 mètres du château de
versailles
inauguré officiellement ce jeudi elle
fait la fierté de la ville
et pour cause quatre grands noms de
l'art de vivre de l'excellence à la
française viennent de s'y installer
première boutique guerlain hors de paris
celle de versailles se veut être un
prolongement du château boiseries style
louis saez lustres majestueux et symbole
de l'astre apporte la touche royale et
bien sûr ce parfum unique dans le flacon
abeilles historique
nous avons vraiment une création
exclusive qui s'appelle la cour des
senteurs versailles qui a été créée par
notre notre parfumeur thierry vasseur et
c'est vraiment un parfum qui est lié à
l'histoire de versailles parce que la
note principale c'est le jasmin pour
retrouver dans les bordures du château
et les notes de cette fleur fétiche de
marie-antoinette ont déjà séduit
nous habitons juste à côté donc ça fait
longtemps qu'on passe devant et on était
très content de voir ça les ouvrir
on attend du jour après jour et voilà et
on est venu aujourd'hui avec les enfants
d'en montrer un peu ce que ce que l'on
pouvait vendre là et on a été très
agréablement surprise et à tel point
qu'on était chez les règles j'ai acheté
le premier parfum je suis la première à
avoir acheté le parfum des senteurs le
voilà je suis la première cliente
voilà me voilà en face
l'institution de la gastronomie
française lenôtre a développé un concept
de boutique snacking avec terrasse à
l'arrière et bientôt un driving côté rue
les gourmands pourront alors découvrir
une nouvelle création
bien évidemment le mac à rojas may il
est lé juste fabuleux parce que c'est
quelque chose d'atypique
c'est quelque chose qui correspond à la
à court des senteurs et donc ce côté un
petit peu doré craquant à quelque part
un petit peu bijoux et surtout ce côté
parfum jasmin fleur de jasmin a qui
donne une belle longueur qui vous avait
juste une petite pointe de vanille donc
on est presque dans un jus une création
d'un jus mais dans l'esprit sucrés dans
la cour des senteurs la maison fabre
présente sa première collection de
maroquinerie et de gants parfumer une
mode lancée par catherine de médicis
juste à côté l'enseigne diptyque propose
en exclusivité un coffret de 3 min
bougies aux fragrances spécial
versailles
la ville a tout mis en oeuvre pour
attirer les touristes depuis la gare
rive gauche un parcours de silhouettes
mène à la cour des senteurs et eaux
usées des parfums qui retrace leur
histoire de manière sensorielle au point
information les visiteurs pourront
acheter des billets pour le château de
versailles notamment au fond de la cour
des senteurs le jardin composé en
plusieurs parties prend forme doucement
encore en travaux il accueillera les
flâneurs le mois prochain